[Música]
nuevamente el republicano Kevin mccarthy
no logró conseguir los votos necesarios
para ser elegido como presidente de la
cámara de representantes en Estados
Unidos pese a los pedidos de apoyo por
parte del expresidente Donald Trump
entre tanto el presidente calificó de
vergonzosa la falta de consenso entre
los conservadores
[Música]
con un discurso enfocado en mejorar la
educación en hacer frente a los reclamos
por la crisis económica y de sanidad el
Primer Ministro británico
las prioridades de su gobierno para el
año 2023 un discurso con el que también
buscó unidad en el Reino Unido Tenemos
reporte desde Londres
la OMS Indicó que las cifras eran
reportadas por china sobre el número de
contagios de covid-19 no representan la
situación real por su parte Beijing
calificó de discriminatorias las
restricciones impuestas por cerca de una
decena de países a Los viajeros
procedentes del país asiático
Muy buenas tardes Bienvenidos a esta
edición de noticias de France 24 soy
Santiago López González vamos a comenzar
en Estados Unidos porque en este país
continúa el bloqueo en la cámara de
representantes tras una nueva derrota
del republicano Kevin mccarthy en la más
reciente Ronda de votaciones todo esto
para elegir al presidente de la cámara
baja del Congreso La derrota de mccarthy
deja en evidencia las divisiones al
interior del partido republicano motivó
por el que el expresidente Donald Trump
pidió a sus compartidarios apoyar a
mccarthy el ala más radical del partido
no lo considera suficientemente fuerte
para presidir la cámara entre tanto el
presidente Joe de calificó de vergonzosa
la falta de consenso entre los
conservadores estas fueron sus palabras
con respecto a la pelea por el portavoz
ese no es mi problema solo creo que es
un poco vergonzoso que se esté tomando
tanto tiempo y la forma en que lo están
haciendo entre ellos y el resto del
mundo está mirando mirando si podemos
juntos
pero en lo que estoy enfocado es en
hacer las cosas y lo que voy a hacer hoy
en Kentucky y Ohio es hacer las cosas
el Primer Ministro británico
a través de un discurso las prioridades
para su gobierno para el año 2023 sunak
hizo énfasis en temas relacionados con
educación unidad y los reclamos en torno
a la crisis económica y de sanidad Luisa
Pulido desde Londres nos amplía la
información escuchemos
en este su primer gran discurso desde
que fue elegido Richie sunak hizo cinco
promesas la primera reducir la cifra de
la inflación que en noviembre de 2022
llegó al 10.7% para lograrlo tendría que
bajarla hasta un poco más del 5% Pero
esto no solo depende del gobierno
británico sino de factores
internacionales como el precio de la
energía también mejorar la economía
promoviendo el aumento de trabajos de
puestos de trabajo con mejores salarios
reducir el endeudamiento público de la
nación recortar la lista de espera que
tienen que tener las personas para poder
ser vistas por un médico o por un
especialista del Sistema Nacional de
salud en eches y una bien controversial
acabar con la inmigración ilegal a
través del Canal de la Mancha con una
legislación mucho más fuerte es decir
que las personas que crucen el canal
desde Francia desde las playas francesas
y lleguen al Reino Unido puedan ser
detenidas y deportadas inmediatamente a
dicho el gobierno
solo en el 2022 cerca de 46.000 personas
llegaron por esta vida Aunque Richi es
un acá presentado ha puesto sobre la
mesa de estas las que son las cinco
prioridades de su gobierno Lo cierto es
que vive un momento de debilidad
política su gobierno porque todos los
días el país está enfrentando huelgas de
diferentes sectores públicos que dan la
sensación de una huelga generalizada de
una huelga general y sobre todo de un
Primer Ministro desconectado de la
realidad del país
el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin ordenó
el despliegue de la fragata almirante
gorskov equipada con misiles y
hipersónicos circón el buque de guerra
ha sido desplegado por primera vez para
un largo viaje que los llevará a aguas
del Océano Atlántico del mar
Mediterráneo y del mar Índico la entrada
de servicio de este navío coincide con
la puesta en marcha también de una
campaña militar centrada en
contrarrestar las amenazas de Rusia y
mantener la estabilidad regional los
misiles circón hacen parte de una nueva
serie de misiles hipersónicos rusos que
cruzan a nueve veces la velocidad del
sonido
Quiero agradecer en primer lugar a los
especialistas en el complejo de la
industria de defensa que crearon y
comenzaron la producción en masa de esta
arma única como ya he dicho no Hay
equivalente en ningún país del mundo
estoy seguro de que esta poderosa arma
permitirá que Rusia se proteja de
amenazas externas potenciales de manera
confiable y nos ayudará a servir los
intereses nacionales de nuestro país y
el ministro de defensa de Rusia elevó 89
el número de sus soldados muertos tras
un ataque ucraniano el día de año nuevo
Rusia sólo había reconocido 63
fallecidos en los combates en la
localidad de mackipca
Moscú culpó al uso ilegal de teléfonos
móviles por parte de los soldados de la
incursión decidiendo que permitió a los
ucranianos determinar las coordenadas
precisas de su ubicación
en una rara conmemoración pública de los
soldados muertos en la guerra cientos de
personas se reunieron en Samara en el
occidente de Rusia muchos de los
soldados que fueron alcanzados por
misiles ucranianos el día de año nuevo
eran de la ciudad
no podemos quebrarnos Y el dolor nos une
se los aseguro
aplastaremos juntos al enemigo
Rusia aseguró que el número de soldados
que perdieron la vida másca era mayor a
los 63 que habían reportado el martes
en la inspección de los escombros de las
construcciones de hormigón armado el
número de nuestros camaradas muertos
llegó a 89
actualmente una comisión Investiga las
circunstancias del ataque pero ya está
claro que la causa principal fue el
encendido y uso masivo por parte del
personal de teléfonos móviles dentro del
alcance de las armas enemigas en contra
de la prohibición
el ataque causó grandes descontento en
la opinión pública rusa criticando
Ucrania y a sus aliados occidentales
también blogueros corresponsales de
guerra incluso legisladores han
expresado su enfado con el mando militar
por la debacle de mcfca andrey
vicepresidente del parlamento manifestó
su descontento por Telegram Es peligroso
y Criminal considerar al enemigo como un
tonto que no ve nada durante el décimo
mes de la guerra poner en cualquier
lugar de los edificios en lugar de
ponerlas en refugios es una ayuda
directa al enemigo a pesar del aumento
del número de fallecidos por parte de
Rusia este no se acerca al reportado por
Ucrania las autoridades del país
aseguraron que fueron 400 los muertos y
300 los heridos y China volvió a
calificar como prácticas
discriminatorias las medidas anticovid
impuesta por varios países a Los
viajeros procedentes de ese país
asiático Japón fue uno de los últimos en
sumarse junto a Estados Unidos Francia
el Reino Unido y también la República de
Corea estos gobiernos temen un rebrote
del virus en sus territorios ante la ola
de contagios de covid 19 que está
viviendo China la OMS dice que la cifra
reportadas por Beijing no representan la
situación real Andrés Meza Muñoz tiene
los detalles en su informe
[Música]
china arremete nuevamente contra los
países que han impuesto medidas
anticovid a viajeros procedentes del
gigante asiático para Beijing se trata
de una politización sobre el tema del
virus
china Siempre cree que las medidas de
prevención de pandemias tomadas por
todos los países deben ser científicas y
apropiadas Y no deben usarse como una
oportunidad para involucrarse en
manipulación política prácticas
discriminatorias o afectar los
intercambios y la cooperación normales
entre las personas cada vez son más los
países que les exigen por ejemplo
pruebas negativas de covid 19 en China
la eliminación de las estrictas
restricciones destinadas a frenar el
virus han desatado Un aumento en el
número de contagios para Europa se trata
de una preocupación legítima en palabras
del gobierno francés y por ello buscan
blindarse
ningún país quiere ver un brote en su
territorio no después de todos los
esfuerzos y sacrificios realizados en
los últimos tres años
Beijing se enfrenta a críticas por el
reporte de sus cifras la Organización
Mundial de la Salud dice que los números
actuales en China no reflejan la
situación real particularmente en
términos de muertes desde el cambio de
política las autoridades Solo han
reportado al menos cinco fallecimientos
diarios mientras expertos
internacionales predicen que sólo este
año se pueden registrar más de un millón
el país se prepara para que una Nueva
Ola del virus golpee las zonas Rurales
ya que millones de personas se alistan
para viajar a sus ciudades de origen
para recibir el año nuevo Chino este 22
de enero
esto en las noticias de France 24
recuerde que a la hora en punto hacemos
una actualización de los hechos más
destacados en América Latina y el mundo
más información y ampliación de otros
temas en France 24.com y en las redes
sociales siga con nosotros buenas tardes
[Música]